hello and welcome to this video I am see
I assume is that you will up soon okay
doesn't he play one before you have
published a book on one before which I
find is a pretty crazy ideas but this
time is flying and one solid opening I
mean a book of one be four over three is
creating you just play the normal line
and the black is slightly better and
maybe I can equalize but that's tough
yeah I don't like this all that much of
my my problems against III are quite
quite clear you watch my videos I have
no recipe against c3 right now okay I'm
just playing like normally she looking
moves and hope I'm not getting
annihilated my development is not good
is the thing and it will be three
Merrick probably can't be canceled after
that will be 795 should be ok just train
[Music]
looks kind of that looks a bit
unambitious I mean why it is still of
course fine but exactly feel like I'm
getting punished for my for my opening
in some way and I failed it was a little
bit unsound to prove it on town okay
with the AIDS you might take and play
there should be seven yeah okay I don't
want to play b6 here looks wrong I could
push the night bag with Luke c8 first
and then think about it still don't want
to play b6 yeah maybe 9 a-3 maybe a
sixer this should be 626 looks harmless
if he goes to a dream okay let's do that
94 I completing and never looked into
that direction that would have been a
good move okay yeah i was i was clearly
a bit too much focused on on the
queenside situation here
so I'm I'm okay well appreciative 493 is
that is idea maybe I can do this that's
an interesting move don't let's try this
Queen takes Knight x 49 a form added to
indeed and now i have to take which
makes the whole situation pretty boring
9f form for not so boring try to turn
nothing so nothing happens if i take and
go the eight is going to should be six
[Music]
it doesn't look good okay loop the eight
and that isolated pawn situation edits
that's lute ly equal yes difficult to
write anything out of such a position
really it's difficult i have d for
actually we will go see four and then
i'll be fine ok so this is just going to
be dead equals but what you have to do
here my time doesn't look good c4s b5
that it's just better for black and
ordered so we will probably take
King everyone I'm going Bishop takes
between right sorry sorry that was a
hallucination i Luke c2 is whoa really
so okay if I take be to t7 an old can
also take hook c to d 7 p-5 I'm ending
up on up the end attending okay so let's
do it I will get both be pawns time
morning yep I know so like that see now
is that Lane if I play the phone all the
way to beat we're putting as king edge
to probably this I will have to do any
way i can try can go to f6 first that's
not bad
okay check I know you can take you five
then that was there was a bit of a
stupid move okay let's see if it still
this is a trick or not yeah probably
probably i'm just going to be just going
to be a draw I was now we can go with
seven what a stupid game and yeah losing
losing is absolutely ridiculous looks
okay I'm just black wait on having a bad
time management and losing is fairly
ridiculous really anyway so let's let's
have a look them I'm actually not
unhappy with how I played the general
game I mean you just didn't get anything
out of the opening and it I did the
right things a 94 I should have played
but that wasn't terrible I mean I just
have a comfortably perfectly comfortable
of position down and this is now getting
really weird thank you for which we
should be three is very strange I mean
after that why the struggling
to hold the probably is this loss the
sending info on the start was truly
octaves Orioles probably okay I wonder
if h4 is a move now because you know is
alienating metal is insulating net it
doesn't matter right hey let's go to g5
okay so this this was okay i just i just
played it too badly afterwards so this
is this is fine and now the question is
is be to winning on norton some
sometimes it does it does win with f65
and so on the engine is implying that it
does i wasn't sure really we can follow
this line a little bit so here I'm king
f2 I guess King e8 King g3 I go over
them and then just probably go up I
still want that much for it I'm not sure
yet even though it's minus 4 are going
to the comp what is the winning idea
then I go here you can always check me
from the back I just I just one now I
escaped the chicks like this yep and I'm
coming up here how exactly am i winning
always f65 doing it I mean he can stay
down sorry
and then the age poem
and I will get you one of course on that
he cannot play King a three cannot play
can eat we cannot play so probably this
and still I'm still not sure how and
winning sorry I mean maybe I'm just
entire and totally stupid but maybe if I
address I just goes down Doctor but if
he starts to chikhli where am I escaping
the checks on g4 and now that cannot yet
now if i can t continues to check me ABS
I'm running and running back in and look
at one yeah okay then it should be when
I wanna show me too often times you
don't want to play the tool because you
need to be two square for the king happy
to us was winning all the time but yes I
wasn't entirely sure I mean what i did
is in terrible i think so g for now wins
as well yeah 27 seconds isn't great to
have I was thinking gee for Nate a bit
okay and this isn't winning our oath I
wasn't quite sure they're guys difficult
I had no time on the clock okay thanks
for watching